hello welcome to this video this is
coverage of the London chess classic the
tournament already has concluded but I'm
still a bit late there with doing
reports on round eight and round nine I
still want to do them to have a complete
picture of the event so this is the
video for around eight I couldn't do it
any any sooner the round was played on
saturday this is going to be published
on Monday I was simply too busy with
them playing chess over the board
teaching and and private things so the
earliest possible date is just exactly
now so let's see what happened in this
eighth round I'm going to kick off with
mvl against Micky Adams on mdl leading
the event with plus two before the round
Adams on fifty percent played all
drawers so we got every week and not a
Berlin Adams is usually going for other
lights in the room and this is the the
complete like the classical here or you
place the marshal sometimes but for this
particular occasion he went for the the
brea variation which is nowadays
arguably the main line of them of them
the main line of the main line let's say
yeah that starts here on 9h 30 k night p
897 the idea of the brass to get this
night on a better square d 77 is the
better square compared to c 6 because it
still allows the sea pawn to play and we
see that later black gets at sea porn
into the game now all normal stuff and
here black gets c5 in yeah Black has
fianchetto with both bishops and odd
pieces in plain this is a typical
position for the brea white probably
enjoys a slight advantage due to that
space that
yes but it is not a lot and it is not
easy to build up on that after C for
blacks intention is to play night to c5
putting more pressure on e form and also
looking to control the Queen side this
is also why MDR goes before important
moment now black should definitely take
on c3 and not allow y to get this bind
on the queenside in a very famous game
Fisher with wide against Spassky first
match game in 1992 Fisher got great idea
and he tripled on the a file and then
opened it up this is now avoided bad if
she just takes that on pass all and gets
some play on the queenside himself c4
okay so white tries to open up the Queen
side as much as possible and here gets a
tape on first glance looks like white is
better and it might be true if anybody
is a bit more comfortable it is wide but
blacks situation is not bad at all he
only has to worry about one thing that
is the a pawn and as long as you control
that you don't have that much to fear
and I think Adams as we have seen is a
very good defender I mean we know that
for years but in that event we have
experienced that in many games that he
can save critical position sometimes
also within a bit of luck like against
metal bar love so give the white play
and really gets us night over to the
Queen side and black is busy defending
his slightly weakish b5 porn here with
the night on c7 and the bishop on t7
it's very very stable this position only
there a porn is slide cause for concern
and black has that quite firmly under
control I think this is a game where not
that much happened there were slight
ways to improve maybe
White's play but they didn't change the
fundamental assessment of the position
it was never something particularly
great for white and black was the super
solid all of the time night at six at
this what's the repetition at the end
yeah Black has neutralized or what would
white-haired here the airport is not
going forward and it is difficult for
wise to make any any solar progress it's
not just difficult it's basically not
not not much there and we also have to
see that maxima Sheila graphs tournament
situation was rather comfortable with
the plus two and there was no need to
get crazy there against someone like
Adam sews Nona has a very tenacious
defender and also a great counter
attacking player if you play your hands
if you overplay your hand let's say okay
let's look at the next game and this is
bri shook her own yarn let's see if I
can pull it up yep that worked gree
shocked aronia um yeah both players on
+1 yeah so interesting situation to
start with GUI shop goes for flank
opening and this is very popular
nowadays said they start with 93 and g3
kind of funny to see that as an opening
have played four years now we see some
of that line played on top level chest
the reason why I played that quite often
over the years said it avoids mainline
theory and it often leads long-term to
interesting play because they are often
lights where there are no quick
simplifications so many pieces stay on
the board in this particular game
aronian goes for that very
classical set up d5 d6 Bishop e7 Knight
f6 quite similar to some Queens gambit
declines position so quickly going for
castling now White has a yeah a basic
choice he can try a form c4 and d4 for a
Catalan opening this is something that
we would see em in a in a later game or
we can play something with c4 and b3
this is what we shall shooters why can't
play with d3 that we will also see later
yeah so d 3 would be the Kings Indian
attack this will be featured in a later
game given a camera or what can go to a
Catalan with c4 and default just played
by Caruana against island with white so
here this is played by Green shock be
three this is getting the game into a
ready system the ready system um usually
has the reputation of being yeah not
very exciting but I'm not really that
sure there are quite a couple of lines
that can be rather interesting
especially if why does is willing to
risk something here in this game Grisha
played in a somewhat hmm how can you
call it in a somewhat simpler way then
then you have to be took on d5 um the
line that i was thinking of that is
indeed quite shop starts with III see
593 and now possibly takes takes it
depends a little bit what black does but
let's say here and then why it can shoot
for something like here Queenie too and
then a possible d 4 or even sometimes
white can go for something active like
moving the night and push the f porn a
couple of very sharp continuations but
we shook decided to just take on d5 this
is a less had a more simpler way to play
but we actually got an interesting
position
the other continuation that I showed was
a little bit more more aggressive so
black Gordon c5 and white efore that's
an important idea putting efore now
black is basically forced to take as
wide as threatening to play d5 and d6 on
a very good day yeah black does not want
to allow this kind of thing to happen
that pawn is the absolute nuisance to
play against so he has to take night
takes and Bishop to c5 yeah look II 242
pretty nice and now 86 yeah Queen went
to be eight because it doesn't have that
many great squares on the CND file and b
8 is just not in anybody's way that
makes some sense I think why does a
little bit better here and we shook I
think plays all them standard normal
looking more so centralizing rupee one
King to h1 to prepare for yeah that is
definitely unwise agenda push the f porn
queen eight and here we go F for played
went back to G 692 this has a has an
idea that however it's not played in the
game h5 here yeah I think there was a
moment where Gris shock could have yeah
built upon his his advantage a little
bit better than he did in the game the
computer points out the possibility of
going before him attacking that bishop
and after Bishop retreats a three can be
played you just keep the Queen side as
is and are satisfied that this bishop
has been driven back the basic white
ideas now to play e5 in the near future
and get the e4 square for night for
example if um if you go like let's say
age 45 and now check just a simple
illustrate what I'm talking about try
something like that happens I think
white enjoys a slight advantage here
route de semanas relatively best defense
yeah using the fact that this Luke is
hanging and you cannot take here let's
say take take 94 this is the kind of
position that white can can play for
he's got more space and the more active
King like a slightly boxed in it looks
like theoretically speaking then white
has the bad bishop it's a dark squared
bishop with all pawns on dark squares
but that doesn't really matter that much
because white also has much more space
and the bishop PA book had come to d6 to
d4 for example putting pressure on this
so light is better here and it's not a
very yeah exciting task to defend this
with black Grisha played quindi one
though which is still okay of course
it's not bad but i think that before
idea was was pretty good that the that
the engine points out Nyjah for angling
for some come to play now we see he got
to that that idea just a little bit
differently yeah and here we get to a
key a key position 94 and Bishop e7 yeah
and here it's a little bit unclear what
we shook intended here with his next
move if he goes gee for now which is the
let's say the obvious obvious looking
move in that same I think wyd still is
kind of okay there's nothing bad
happening to him what white has to be a
little bit cautious about is over
expansion that you put your paws for but
he has put many pawns forward and that
you kind of yeah expose yourself too
much
leave too many holes in your position
behind and this can easily happen in
this situation I think yeah it's kind of
ok but what has to be careful with what
he did he played them with f5 I think he
definitely gets on the wrong track
because now black gets handed this e5
square immediately and this gets to be
uncomfortable White has two very
impressive looking nights but it's just
that they don't threaten that much black
went to grab the illusion and has a
absolute key decision here here black I
think could have played a better enemy I
think it's very obvious once you see
what happens that he could have played
better black has more than one move here
to just continue the game in a way the
way well that he played it's an
immediate draw it took on g3 very normal
looking move but white has a drawing
tactic hmm so black should have tried to
continue the game as he is a bit better
with this bishops and whites King
position being somewhat shaky in the
long run the engine and the engines
suggest move like Bishop takes d5 for a
simple solution or the little bit more
sophisticated Queen create a hoping for
this variation which is of course very
cooperative why should not take on v6
but here black isn't fantastic shape
yeah it's just it's just great the the
threat is sometimes to just take and get
in Queenie one check and white now does
not have that tactic that he has in the
game in the game he went chea which now
can be completely refuted by King to age
seven now but in that pawn is covered
and hear what is completely out of ideas
he cannot just go back as this and this
check check is a pretty pretty big
disaster
so what was the problem with that move
White had just witnessed tactic not at
age six check yeah always look for
checks and captures it's an old mantra
of the chess teacher and here check is
indeed a big issue for black hmm if he
moves the King now white is able to take
and black has no reason to go for this
position his King is insecure 95 is on
the radar it just it looks bad so black
has to take it there is no choice there
and then Knight f6 check is forcing a
draw so Grisha haddam yeah pretty much i
found and in news agency exit exit there
check and black cannot avoid this
perpetual check so there were chances a
little bit for both sides in that game
but they weren't taken and at the end a
draw in this game by perpetual check
okay i already mentioned that there were
a couple of other night f3 g3 um setups
we had kawana are not let's look at this
game here we had the same kind of
situation out of a night f3 g3 kind of
setup we got into cattle and am so
honored place this main set up in almost
all of his games and is usually quite
successful there yeah i mean black has a
hard time to win a game there ever but
he also does not use off her wanna know
a bit surprisingly goes for Queen a form
um this is almost the same thing as
Quincy too but the modern main line here
definitely is Quincy to a 6 a-4 trying
to prevent the b5 move a little bit
longer after Queen a4 a6 black and
threatening to keep the pawn with B file
so you have to take
and now black gets in that queenside
development this is of course an
absolutely legitimate main line and it
was the total main line of the Catalan
let's say in the late 2000s two thousand
eight nine ten eleven this kind of thing
this kind of period of time but nowadays
it's almost been completely replaced by
the a four lines that that I had
mentioned um so Bishop b2 played by
Caruana this is the main move nowadays
with white sometimes angling for that
weird-looking move Bishop to a five yeah
checking this pawn bishop d6 by anand
and now 95 this is a somewhat rare line
that kawana place and it's not supposed
to be very dangerous um maybe he was
trying for something let's say well
forgotten because the general reputation
of this this plane here is not that
great and in the game there is no
particular reason to form for for a
revival let's say black was completely
okay Nancy for played by anand and
Bishop see one yeah sometimes the top
players they go for somewhat forgotten
lines too yeah to just test their
opponents and do they really do they
nurse didn't know what why a particular
line is not supposed to be that great or
have they forgotten the reason and this
can be a good recipe sometimes I just
ask a couple of questions they're like
okay you really know how to equalize
here or not and if they know it okay it
might be equal and if they don't you
might have a good game it's not a bad
kind of risk reward ratio so here Bishop
see one back Caruana that looks like a
pretty pretty smallish move let's look
at alternatives why couldn't you go e5
is that some kind of awkward fork hmm
black can play age six quite a funny
reply if white now takes one of the
pieces the night gets taken
and ultimately white has to think about
his development yeah he still has got
these at home that's not that great
actually if Wyatt goes back to have
three black has this funny reply with a
big walk yeah white cannot win material
with you five it's quite quite funny
okay he went Bishop c1 and on and went
h6 it seems that Island already had to
kind of recollect his prep or you just
was just playing over the board kawana
still wasn't preparation up to here went
back to f3 and now honored went Knight
to g4 yeah even on that level we all
love we all have Forks okay so of course
karana paid attention to that but he
still reply in an interesting way played
rookie one Bishop c5 renewing that idea
and now we just ignored the whole set
whole thing with 93 yeah he sacrificed
in exchange him thing is if black takes
it like gender check check then why'd
sacrifices this change here and goes 95
and here white has a very nice
compensation for his exchange the bishop
only three Hanks and if it goes back
then white will go here and the prospect
of a knight on c6 and the other night on
d5 is is very very tempting to give in
exchange for in fact white would have a
great position here and I mean black may
be able to defend but this is the kind
of position that you can give a computer
and it will defend like yeah maybe
perfectly but for human player this is
kind of a horror scenario to being faced
with those two nights right at your
doorstep it's it's just totally
uncomfortable so Anna didn't do that he
went queen to d6 interesting choice
and I think a good choice he shouldn't
have gone for 93-91 yeah now koala felt
that he has to do something about the 83
square root d8 h 3 and now we got a
funny little tactic Queen D 1 yeah looks
like a queen sacrifice but ultimately it
is just a big trade big trade of
material as the Queen now is hanging
white has to take it Teague's Teague's
chat and here black get stuff back check
never get to this position with rookie
night against rogue and bishop this
position is a little bit easier for wide
to play because the pawn structure is
somewhat static and white has chances to
get good squares for his night however
under some quite known for his the
tenacious defense and he got to this
position now with BNC porn yeah Gainey
giving some counter play I think eyelids
defensive players pretty instructive is
not being passive but he tries to use
his his pieces and his Queen side pawns
for counter play here come c 3 here
comes the beep on um i think the next
move here Carano at age 5 is making it a
little bit easier a little bit easier
for I wanted to to draw after g 5y it
has a thing slightly better chances to
do something even though black is not in
terrible shape the thing is that black
can often do this as you did in the game
yeah try to get this active and then try
to get the a porn with the help of Rue
gate I mean here white can of course
continue but I think at the end Black
will be able to hold
in the game we had aged 5 and again a 5
intending a 4 and this is not something
that white can ignore if the parts get
to run even more it will be dangerous so
white X b3 b2 and white has to stop the
beep on but now look at it and we see
the counter play comes against the a
pawn king here cakes antiques antiques
of course blackwell usted beep on but
let's do it let's read it differently
black should abandon the beep on and
activate the rook for defensive duties
on the King side so this is just given
away and now black activates a scheme to
f 7j andy sixx yeah this is the active
defense that I was talking about black
shirt should not sit passively but
rather give up a part temporarily to to
make progress in terms of his peace
activity he wants to get play against
those pawns here come on ultimately
exactly a couple of checks but then took
he didn't have any other way
constructive to continue the game rapid
after this and King you five are not is
able to save the game quite comfortable
comfortably yeah sorry yeah King up to
h4 of course yeah never too late to
blunder you can shuttle blunder the
h-bond so up here and black him to stay
on the fourth romanticos check here you
will get the pawn them and they played
up to bear kings I think rather correct
let's say draw or um gap a game where
the equilibrium was not disturbed that
much kawana was slightly better
certainly in this in this end game but
we she defended quite precisely yeah a
bad event for Ireland and kind of a
event for caruana is also sitting there
with all drawers after
okay next game to look at is to Paolo
with white against Magnus cars in the
world champion so yeah to pull off with
a very bad event Carlton with his great
window when a camera from around seven
definitely now seeing that he's got some
slight chances left in that event to to
get somewhere maybe even win the overall
thing with this Plus once Coy's actually
close behind mdl end giri who goes sits
at plus-2 sorry giri is on +1 after 17 I
can keep screwing this up it's so close
right it's just easier if somebody is
dominating with plus five or so ok took
power of cars to pile of bad event
Carson has to win so what is he going to
do he plays a solid opening it doesn't
play something crazy this one the
accelerated or the improved sorry tirage
defense after C takes black takes with
the night this is a an opening that I
can really recommend to people who want
a simple reply in the Queens gambit once
the night is out nf3 you can learn that
like in one afternoon and it leads to
absolutely playable positions it is not
super exciting but it's very difficult
to get an exciting position if you want
to invest in otay this is a typical kind
of problem then people want to play the
most exciting chest but don't work for
it that's not happening you can try to
play exciting sharp openings but then
you most likely will have bad positions
if you don't work on them so but playing
solidly with them not so much work as
possible and the line nearby cars is a
good example of that after you for like
ticks and ticks chat chicks and test and
we get to this position yeah very
logical sequence of moves White has
better center efore ad for that Pandu
but what black hands is a very clear
idea and he plays
97 he plays b6 and he puts it on b7 and
then brings the night over that night
now has no bishop again to fear that it
can pin so the night is very stable on
f6 if white goes 'if I've black is happy
that he's got the square d 5 so it's a
very simple setup bishop on b7 knight on
f6 queen will often come to e7 or
sometimes also on d6 when there is no no
fork in the game h6 was played covering
the h porn that there's no e 595 coming
and a five year to pull off gets to
trade this and we get here which it
should be somewhat we should be equal
right there is there should be something
great happening but in the actual game
we see that after a couple of trades in
92 roxy three after a couple of trades
in fact white got himself into a
slightly uncomfortable position why is
that well never look at this here
black's pieces are just more active
those are ways to put pressure on the f
porn has also 94 on the other hand
blacks position is a little bit more
compact he's got the porn back on your
six and has this very classical kind of
set up on the King side it's very safe
and very very solid it's very difficult
to take anything there on the other hand
the f2 porn is exposed why it would very
much love to play a 42 III and be saved
there again but okay that's not
something you can do according to the
chest rules difficult for now for the
part of the defendants he decided to go
e 5 not an easy decision because that
way you give black that great square or
d5 okay so it continued like that
and also we had a queen trade yeah this
is a position that is of course not fun
at all for whites to play why only five
there is a pawn often that kind of
advanced pawn can be a great supporting
unit for a let's say King side attack
because it takes away important squares
like f6 or sometimes it can help a piece
to establish itself on d6 but this is
not a middle game this is an end game
and here the issue is that this part is
alone on d5 there is no support by it's
a friend there they f porn um and that
means white always has to worry about
that pawn what black wants to do is he
wants to win that porn under favorable
circumstances also trying to undermine
that night position means of the Jeep on
so this is what why try to prevent a g4
and Carson I came up with a king night
back there takes tease g4 and back so
white now has something that it's not
like a fortress that is the wrong kind
of expression and it's definitely not a
fortress that you cannot yeah I cannot
break open or anything what it tries is
basically setting up a different purely
defensive set up and just try to try to
hold that game yeah it just can just
it's a sit-in wait strategy yeah so
Carson was trying in this scenario for a
very long time and it's a bit difficult
to do any commentary on that because it
is a very slowish kind of play slowly
gradually going forward one interesting
thing is that at one point here he
managed to get enough activity check
okay check fast forward a little bit
no but he managed the love activity yeah
you have to be ready to play very long
games against the world champion check
he took that pond and Carlton it seems
that later he stated in an interview
that he felt that if it wasn't for the
50 move rule that he had very decent
winning chances here if he was not
forced to take the porn thing is if we
go back here the last trade on the last
poem where we have to look for the last
pawn move or the last trade it wasn't
move 39 so on move 89 it would become a
draw and we all move 84 so he decided
then to take the pawn and after the pawn
gets captured it is a relatively clear
cut roll yeah the rook endgame was three
against two is a theoretical draw at
least and topple off certainly was was
happy that he got into that um it seems
that cars indeed would have had some
chances if you would be able to like
somehow I mean it's not a little move
King to c5 within I don't either but
yeah or maybe get the King to d5 yeah
just continue to slowly push forward
without taking material too early it's
possible but there is the 50 move rural
and I think it also that this is a very
good rule you might find the autumn
situation where um where there would be
a different result if there wasn't it
wasn't for the 50 move who were but
there are so many other instances where
yah where that rule is necessarily a
necessary to avoid
absurdly long games and here I mean this
could have easily gone to move like 130
or 50 or whatever and then you can
shuffle around endlessly yeah until one
sides clock is totally down and it's
it's just not something that you can
seriously do like you abolish the 50
movable so it took that pond and
continued of us a little bit here but
here you don't need try to be as
technically the verses to part of the
whole to draw you basically just have to
make sure that you don't fall out of
your chair okay so a draw between the
tail end and the world champion slightly
disappointed maybe a disappointing for
cars but it's mean to part of its like
raided like word number two or three
before the events so even though he has
a rotten event it doesn't mean that
cards and wins automatically against him
and well it's right heart in that
technical end game but didn't manage to
grind out a win okay so let's look at
the final game of that round that
coverage also it is Gary Nakamura yeah
already announced that we had this kind
of opening here and so identical with
the Grisha shock our own young game but
Giri went for d3 this move um yeah it
doesn't look very aggressive t3 but is
in fact a more aggressive move in a way
then some of the other continuation
there it ran supposes now to the Kings
Indian attack in this kind of situation
um why place the Kings Indian with
reverse colors in a way but black
already is committed to a relatively
modest setup that is rarely chosen
against the Kings Indian from the white
side um here Geary of course has a
choice he can play the movie 5 that kind
of curious here became yeah okay just
screwed up the reading of my notes he
can play the movie 5 immediately a
setting to get this kind of situation
with the established outposts where
white quite often tries for a king
cytotec or you can keep the tension for
a little while and this is what gear we
did he played it like that still keeping
that option open but not yet playing e5
hereafter be five he decided to play in
a different way it would have been a bit
more interesting maybe also for for us
I'm here to see the movie 5 after a 5 9
27 we get this this line that was played
a lot in the 1970s let's say his main
expert on the black side was Wolfgang
woman Adam East German Grand Master who
got that a lot from the French defense
very sharp very sharp kind of game with
wider putting the night here let's say
here this is how it is often played and
white was here and so on just roughly
here and tries to attack on the Kings
side while black tries to win on the
queenside would have been a very
interesting kind of situation but give
me when a for he had a different idea in
mind before and now taking that doesn't
look so interesting but it has some
points when white wants to do is he
wants to basically claimed that black
has weakened himself more then it helped
himself with all those pawn moves the
pawn on c5 might be slightly exposed
this kind of idea um however black
doesn't have any serious weakness at the
moment and it shouldn't really put black
into in too much trouble pookie ate all
that looks fairly normal that a pawn
push yeah they used to irritate black a
little bit and I
that all in all with the this very sound
solid development that black has he
should be quite okay there is a
situation a little bit later and I want
to address we got that trade n night
back to d7 and Bishop back to f4 yeah I
mean if we look at the the pure space um
black looks fine on the other hand it's
not so easy for black to change anything
about the pawn structure why its bishops
here have a good I have a good setup and
you cannot just play d4 or or any other
paw push if you play c4 for example
Knight d4 here is absolutely awkward so
it's not easy for black to make any
headway with this pawns went back here
and now c3 played by give you the idea
would be if white gets in to trade the
sea pawns then the thirsty four square
would be very nice for wide yeah for
example let's say um what did nakamura
play red rook c8 but just some some
scenario like that would be can't
favorable learn from where appendix e
eight and now Quincy too yeah if white
takes now there is a seafoam here also
and this is not advisable for white
Queens it to instead and now d 4 yeah
this is an aggressive-looking move I'm
not sure that it is that great to be
honest because it also gives why Dead
Sea foursquare it's kind of a funny
strategy it felt a little bit also like
gooey wanted to yeah put himself into a
solid sound situation and wait what no
cameras is trying to do a meanie was
obviously on obviously but yeah but it
cannot it must must have been a pretty
frustrating experience
to lose around seven game after that
long find against council and now he has
to play there again with black against
geary and maybe one deserve a bit too
much from the position i don't know but
maybe give his choice of position type
was influenced by that idea ya know now
can we were up late age six edge for an
hour to go and see three thing is that
after this i feel that white has gained
a little bit more from the whole from
the whole procedure it wasn't necessary
there were a couple of interesting
alternatives for example be three year
was possible queen bee to NC for
consequences are not so easy to assess
but something like Knight takes bishop
cheeks and pawn takes and then let's say
95 shouldn't be that bad that point is
rather dangerous after all this is a
line I'm given by buy stock fish for
example a couple of interesting
possibilities that black could have gone
for I mean this is not like terrible
it's not terribly bad or so but I feel
that with this kind of situation white
um must feel pretty okay considering
that it looked like he had a spaced is
it rod doing all of a sudden that pieces
are rather active this is how it went
and now when I camera grab that porn
yeah it's still not terribly bad for him
and I said but it gets critical now 95
and route d1 and Knight to c6 yeah I
think like still has pretty decent
chances to defend but now I think he
just yeah lost his nerves a little bit
oh yeah I got to go too nervous or so um
there are still ways to try to defend
this for example black should probably
try to take and give up the exchange
here something like this is some is from
there's still some hope for black to
defend this
it's not a lot of fun but it's
alternative the alternative that
Nakamura went for is just losing a mere
lane so he probably should have given
given the exchange there it's um
basically not avoidable anymore this is
what he did he gave the Queen yeah 4422
bishops in some cases this is not a bad
compensation for example if you imagine
just for argument's sake we would have
had looks traded and there won't
wouldn't be any a pawns yeah then I
think Black has very decent chances to
draw this but the way this is here the
drawing chance are basically
non-existent the main thing is that wide
now has Queen 84 and geary now place
this with with utmost precision Queen a
for attacking the rook yeah what is
black supposed to do now if he goes back
with this rook then what is going
probably f4 just pushing further in the
game and I kambou I tried this move but
this is also not helping him because
giri has a strong reply which he found
he played this now excellently I looked
to the eight this is the most powerful
move going directly on the back rank
yeah Black now has no big choice he has
to yeah okay he didn't do that he played
c4 but the choice is the computer wants
to do this but ultimately it doesn't
help it leads to the same situation as
we had in the game basically this is
what played and was played in the game
he gave back the exchange and now
entered with the green and it's
something that you first of all you have
to calculate correctly and this is this
might just look super easy if you just
sit there at home and have your engines
running but you still have to absolutely
make sure that you
in the position but should be success
now h5 very precise and black gets
nowhere if he pushes the polar now check
then Queen here and this is just a win
we're not going to take this him yeah
rope g5 was tried kingi to MC 3 n.o f4
and here nakamura resigned he doesn't
have any decent square for his rook yeah
something like this is again just losing
that bishop so a very disappointing
continuation of that event for Nakamura
we had a really good tournament beating
honors and being on +1 but then he lost
the game against cars around 780 again
against giri in round 8 to black games
that yeah basically ended any ambition
um yeah for winning that event that the
tournament or winning the overall grand
chest or so after round eight the
situation is that mvl maxima Sheila
Grove and anish giri are leading the
event with plus 2 followed by a couple
of players with plus 1 is Aronian with
plus 13 show plus 1,000 plus 1 I think
that's it right kuranes on fifty percent
island has a minus coin to pile of has
yeah tons of losses and no win so all
was set for a very very interesting and
enclose ninth round that I'm going to
cover shortly probably will be on like
tuesday morning or so i don't get get to
do it earlier okay thanks for watching